is there a science is there an art to
cooking meat well and the different
kinds of meats
is there something you can convert into
words
in to say ideas
how to bring out the best out of what
particular meat
whatever steak we're talking about
whatever beef we're talking about is
there something that can be said
the basic approach to cooking
any type of meat beyond the artistry of
it
is pretty scientific and it's what type
of
muscle is it in the animal and what's
the surface area to volume ratio
okay so let's look at those two
questions so the first piece is
what's the type of muscle in the animal
what's the functionality
you don't necessarily need to know that
um to evaluate it but you need to
understand
is it a tender muscle that's not used
very frequently in the animal
or is it a big load-bearing muscle that
gets a lot of action like the cheek
right or the shin or the those pieces
the muscles like um those along the
spinal cord that make up rib eyes and
new york stakes and things those aren't
very exercised
they're they're right next to the spinal
cord spinal cord is doing most of the
work there they're kind of like
stabilizing muscles around this big
functional piece of
of skeletal structure in the animal
other muscles like the ones around the
diaphragm with the flat iron stakes and
skirt stakes and things those are those
are really functional muscles that are
doing a ton and moving and
if they're moving a lot what happens
well functionally they've got
lots of muscle sheaths because muscles
that move frequently
have to do a lot of like complex
contraction
that's why you know there's um in the
cheek for example there's
tons of visible fiber of like
collagenous connective tissue
that connective tissue is everything
in how the meat cooks because connective
tissue
doesn't respond to high heat with
becoming more tender
muscles do right they can get a sear on
them you can cut them and eat them the
collagenous tissue will glom
up and get really tough so you either
have to liquefy it with
really low slow heat with moisture
right or you have to barely cook it and
that's so that's the major piece so
that's the question of life why wouldn't
you just throw a brisket on the grill
okay it's not about the fat you can cut
the fat out the reason you're not going
to throw a brisket on the grill and cook
it hot and fast is got too much
collagenous connective tissue in it
those are these giant muscles that have
all this collagen and these fibers and
tendons in them effectively
so you're never going to be able to just
cook that up hot fast
so that's the first piece it's like what
where's this muscle in the architecture
of the animal
and then what does that mean for what's
going on in the muscle
and that's actually more important than
fat content
we get really kind of we pay a lot of
attention to fat content in muscles
you can make a steak tender if it
doesn't have a ton of fat in it it
actually has more to do if there's if
there's collagen and connective tissue
in it
that's fascinating i never even thought
about that i just
i thought it kind of uh universe i mean
it adds to the
the texture of the meat the chewiness of
the meat
but you're saying it's also adds to uh
how
heat how it reacts to heat how the
entirety of the meat
reacts to heat and the fat is not as
important to that
as the the calories the fat will make
the flavor more delicious
right like it'll add anxiousness and
mouth feel and things like that but
the all the connective tissue in meat
and in some of the cuts like that we ate
a skirt steak last night you could see a
web
of that collagen sheath on the outside
on a ribeye that same collagen sheath is
this big there's only one it goes around
the outside okay because it's just
that muscle there's one large muscle
fiber so
that specific it's a myelin sheath right
that's
that material needs moisture and low and
slow heat to become
tender the other side of that is that
when it becomes tender it liquefies and
it adds all this beautiful
gelatinous consistency that's what bone
broth is that's why
like a slow cooked pork shoulder is so
delicious
it's not that it's full of all that fat
that fat's also great but
a lot of that mouthfeel comes from that
really beautiful
dissolved collagen so when you're
looking like how do i understand how i'm
going to cook a piece of meat
that first fork in the road is how is
this going to respond to heat
and what's the appropriate cooking
technique
then the second piece is that surface
area to volume ratio
and that's important because the heat is
going to impact the meat
through the surfaces of the meat that
are in contact with the heat
so if i have a steak that's three inches
thick i'm gonna cook it extremely diff
differently from my
from a steak that's a half inch thick or
three quarters of an inch thick
and that's the major and that's the
truth if i have a piece of pork shoulder
that's cut into cubes versus having a
whole pork shoulder
that surface area to volume ratio that's
going to totally change how i cook it
and same things like pot roast and a
beef stew
would be the same cut of meat right but
how i cook them is going to change based
on the surface area of volume because
you've got to let
moisture and heat work its way into the
center of the meat
and that's going to be determined by the
amount of surface of the meat that's in
contact with whatever cooking liquid or
heat you've got
is there different sources of heat to
play with like a big flame versus a
small or maybe even like almost no flame
like over coals all that kind of stuff
is there some
science to the source of heat in how it
plays with the meat
well there's indirect heat and direct
heat and
that really is mostly about temperature
okay
in more than actual i mean smoke is
important
as well that can permeate but really the
smoke doesn't go into the center of most
cuts that you barbecue it'll come it's
like a smoke ring
it's a it's a you know it's maximum like
half an inch on the outside
maybe a little bit deeper on a really
long slow cook so they
but this the smoke that's does create a
ton of flavor on the surface of the meat
um but that's so the indirect allows you
to have smoke contacting it and then a
very very low and slow heat
and what that does is indirect heat
will be low and slow enough
that the center of the meat will get
warm at the same time as the exterior of
the meat
and it'll all cook equally and all get
equally tender
if you go very hot and fast you risk the
interior of the meat
not getting right you kind of create a
shell on the on it
and you slow down the interior of the
meat which you actually want to do with
something like a steak
where you want to keep it rare on the
inside so it's really indirect versus
direct then once you get into
direct heat right look at in that
category there's wood
charcoal gas right that's about it and
those are
meaningfully different they're
meaningfully different charcoal and wood
that's more of there's more poetry and
wood there's a little bit more flavor
not functionally very different but gas
versus charcoal wood
is very different um and that's because
of the actual
scent of the of the cook right the scent
of the flavor
um and then there's a i think an
evenness of heat distribution that comes
off of charcoal
that's different from gas because no
matter how awesome your gas grill is you
do have hotter
and cooler spots so gas grills are
typically you can kind of control for
that if you just are going really hot
and fast
yeah which is why grass grills are fine
if you're just like throwing that steak
on get a
hard sear on those burgers put a crust
on it that's fabulous for that that's
perfect
when you're doing things that do better
with a low and slow
cook like let's say a whole tenderloin
or
chicken thigh that's going to be a
little bit
less elegant on gas than on charcoal
versus wood so when you have more more
kind of nuance
in the low slow cook over the natural
fuels
you